on today's show we're going to talk to a
young woman who's struggling with
anxiety after experiencing a deep
trauma with a close family friend we're
going to talk to a young man who's
worried about his dad
and his dad's obesity and how he might
help his father become more healthy
and we're going to talk to a young woman
whose father's an alcoholic
and who didn't show up and continues to
hurt her and her sisters
stay tuned
hey what is up i'm john and this is the
dr john deloney show
we're taking your calls about your life
your relationships your relational iq
how you interact with other human beings
including yourself
sometimes especially yourself we're
talking about your mental health
your families right i want to help you
rethink re-examine
and reimagine just being a person
right and how to take the the next
crooked
wobbly bold step into whatever it is
you're doing
whatever it is you're trying to
reconnect to or heal
we may talk about integrity loss when
things fall apart
infidelity we may talk about how to love
again
what do we owe people who've hurt us in
the past
and we may talk about this all right
we're going to talk about the annoying
things
segment here so the inside joke here
is that i'm not annoyed by much of
anything a few things drive me crazy
but most of most of the time i'm a
pretty laid back guy
i just don't get worried about a lot of
stuff and so i ask people around the
office
i ask my family members my buddies hey
what's something that really annoys you
and it ends up in this spot on the show
and so today i asked the producer of the
show james childs
hey i need something for the annoying
segment and he said
emoji gif people via text
people who only speak in emojis or gifs
and i was like yeah that's awesome until
i realized
that's me well played james childs well
played
so i like to respond so it kind of
started this way
um where are you
and you could usually tell if someone
was over the age of 60 and texting
because they would use the letter r
and the letter u right or you knew they
were 11
and they just tried to it would just say
w-r-e-u
right and then it moved to hey
i'm gonna give you a long long text
about my relationships and how my house
caught on fire and my dad passed away
and someone just replied
okay right idiots they would just reply
k
and that moved to like a thumbs up
or a fist bump and evidently apple is
heavily invested in us
reclaiming hieroglyphics because now
there's just whole generation of human
who just speaks
in pictures right
and then we discovered the gifts every
movie ever made
is now a joke and it's awesome and
that's how i communicate with everybody
and what i've learned over the last few
years is that people
have different relationships with movies
than i do and
they think those mean different things
than i mean so here's the deal
james well done it's annoying when we
speak in gifts
and uh text message emojis
i get it well played and seen
unbelievable making fun of me on my own
show but
here's what i am gonna commit to i'm
gonna commit to texting less in 2021
about four years ago i bought a flip
phone and i was like i'm not texting
anymore bro i'm going old school we're
just going to be humans again
and then i realized i just nobody talked
to me
they would send these crazy text
messages and i would get it and i would
be like
oh wow
right and it took like eight hours to do
a text right it was ridiculous
and then i would try to call them and
then my friends who i've known and loved
for years would say
hey why are you calling me why don't you
just text me back idiot
and so i had to go back to the old foam
so i'm not going to pretend like
like i'm getting a cave man club and
like a
leopard-skinned loincloth i'm going to
attack through i'm not going to do that
but
i am going to commit to texting less i'm
going to call people more
so in addition to not eating sugar
this is going to be 20 21 man let's
start calling each other just be humans
again
but the one caveat is if you have an
awesome gif go ahead and send that
anyway
so that's a long intro to say
i am here for whatever is going on in
your world and i'm actually going to use
words when you call
words when you um shoot me an email
so whatever's going on in your heart in
your home or your head give me a call at
one eight four four
six nine three thirty two ninety one
that's one eight four
four six nine three thirty two ninety
one or go to johndaloni.com
show fill out the form it goes directly
to kelly daniel and her team
and they will get in time contact with
you
to have you on the show all right let's
go straight to the calls today
first want to wave to everybody we now
moved up to the studio
we have a live studio audience drum roll
please
i'm counting them four four people out
there
i'm telling you guys this is we're
raising the roof
up here my mom plus four new listeners
this is big big and the camera just
panned on y'all so if any of y'all are
witness protection you're probably gonna
want to
run all right let's go to anna in
columbia south carolina
anna what is up hey john how are you i'm
so good how are you
i'm okay all right let's get into it how
can i help
okay so about a year and a half ago my
fiance's brother um drown in the pool in
the backyard
oh my gosh was it in in
your home um it's where i live yes okay
all right i'm so sorry to hear that so
tell me about it
so ever since then i've kind of had like
this anxiety or this
i guess ptsd with people being alone in
the house
yeah absolutely so anytime anybody's
like by themselves i have to like if i
hear a loud noise i go check on them
try to make sure that they're not passed
out or anything right
and um and it's just like lately it's
just been
kind of bothering me because i'm about
to leave for school
so i don't know how to deal with it with
me not even being at home
yeah so let's back out a little bit so
what happened with your
um your fiance's brother um
so he was home for the summer and um
he swam every day and we don't know what
happened
hmm it's time he had epilepsy
okay and um he took medication for it
but
no one knew he was in the pool and we
weren't home the minute we got home we
went in the backyard and found them
uh okay so i was there for that
cpr on them and yeah
so you have probably been told this but
i want to reiterate it
you experienced the deepest
trauma that a person can experience
outside of direct parental abuse
and i want to make sure you're honoring
how hard of the thing that you i want
you to make sure that not only i know
you're feeling it but intellectually i
want you to know
that what you experience people are not
supposed to experience they're not
supposed to go through that
and that's hard and every system in your
body knows now
that that can happen and you now
have parts of your brain that are
scanning every part of your environment
to make sure that
you are in control and that you make
sure that nobody ever goes through that
again
and especially you never go through that
again right
yes sir so how is your
fiance doing um so my fiance
uh he's a high functioning artist
autistic okay
so he um he's pretty quiet about his
emotions like he obviously talks to me
about it and stuff and
more for him it's just that was the
worst day of his life right
and it's hard because
i try to bottle mine up to help him yeah
and when you do that anna you're
drowning both of you
right you're experiencing this again
it feels like you're trying to help him
by bottling yours up
but it compounds the problem
and i'm i'm asking this because i care
about you
being engaged or being connected to a
high autistic
in many ways have you been experiencing
the grief of this alone
um no he's actually talking like he's
really good at communication
that's one thing he's worked very hard
on to be good at it but he can be great
at communication but is he good at
connection
does he have those skills and abilities
yeah i i would say he does he does ask
me how i'm doing i mean
the week after every night he asked me
how i was beautiful
and even to this day he asked me are you
okay you know
he'll sometimes feel ill something
obviously grief is comes in waves and
some nights are really bad for him and
some days
you know yeah they seem pretty normal
so at the end of the day this is
exhausting and debilitating huh
yeah yeah how did you grieve this loss
um it all kind of the thing is was so
sudden for me because i was
i'm not like you know an outsider but i
i'm the fiance
so a lot of it i was trying not to be
too in the way of it because i felt like
even though i was directly connected to
it i'm not directly related to them
yeah but there's there's there's the
familial loss right
there's the family loss and you are an
outsider to that
but i'm asking you how did you grieve
with coming home opening up a gate and
seeing somebody that you
that you knew who wasn't breathing
anymore the process
of cpr the process of seeing somebody
loaded up into
a ambulance taken to the hospital
the pronouncement all of those things i
get that there's a family i'm asking you
how did you personally grieve
and what i'm hearing you say is you
didn't is that right
pretty much okay until you process this
grief
it's going to continue to haunt you it's
going to continue to hold you down
and by bottling it up and going back to
what i said earlier you are
you are reenacting this over and over in
an effort to make sure it never
ever happens again
and so you have to decide i want to
process
this trauma
and if that is with your boyfriend great
if that's what the professional great
if that's with a group of girlfriends
that can hear you and you can be
vulnerable with
great if you have family that's close to
you and connected great
but you have to make the decision that
i'm going to process
this grief and it's not going to be a
one-time event it's going to be
over a series of days and weeks and
probably
years it will probably be a long time
before you walk
into a backyard and see a pool and your
heart doesn't drop into your stomach
okay yes sir and part of the grief part
of recognizing that grief having gone
through that process
is understanding this is coming and that
way it doesn't shock you
it doesn't knock you down it just it
just hits your chest
you're able to take that deep breath and
then
reset your thoughts right so here's a
couple of things i want you to do
the first thing is if you haven't
already and you've probably heard me say
this 100 times
i'm going to say it a thousand times
more i want you to
write him a letter because there's a
part of me
that guesses i'm just gonna take some
guesses here that you
think i probably should have been there
if i had just been home
if one of us hadn't gone out if one of
us had just been there then
fill in the blank yeah i guess the
hardest part of that is his dad was
working from home
right and he didn't even know didn't
even and we didn't know and we were
eating
breakfast before he went outside it just
exactly and so you start trying to
reverse engineer what happened
as a way of replaying and trying to
recontrol a situation
and your brain goes on a loop and it
never hops off that loop until you stop
and grieve this
grief is the way you stop the loop and
you just put a period at the end of the
sentence and say
oh my good god almighty this happened
right and when you do that there will be
waves of sadness there will be waves of
relief there will be waves of guilt
there will be
all of that feeling and all that emotion
that you will finally let your body
cycle through and you've got some
extraordinary
biological capacities to to work through
that stuff and if you've got great
people in your life
they're going to help you're going to
they're going to help you process this
as well right because
people are your emergency fund for life
you cannot process trauma by yourself
right but you'll work through this and
then
have you heard me talk about david
kessler's purple elephant yet
uh i think i have before okay i wanna do
it one more time with you and then i'm
going to do it a thousand times more
right as long as this podcast lasts
i want you to close your eyes and
picture a red horse
in your driveway okay okay
you got it yeah then i want you to
picture a yellow
hat on that red horse okay
all right and i want you to picture that
red horse just looked at you right in
the eyes and he's kind of smiling weird
okay you got that in your head yeah
all right now open your eyes you just
prove to everyone
that you can control your thoughts
okay here's why that's important
you're going to be walking along the
sidewalk somewhere and you're going to
see somebody that
looks like your fiance's brother
and your heart will sound every alarm it
has your heart will start racing
your stomach will get with that warm
feeling right
you'll get a headache your fingers will
go cold
and then you have an instant moment to
decide
am i going to focus on that image i have
in my head
of doing cpr or am i going to focus on
that image of
the hilarious swimmer that used to come
in and poke fun
at me and his brother you get to decide
which one of those images you meditate
on
are you going to meditate and you're
going to think about and let dwell in
your heart in your head
the picture of him that's in your mind
of him in the pool
and he's not moving and you instantly
know something's not right
or are you going to say nope nope and
you're gonna
put a picture of of him in your mind
when he was doing something silly
when he was being goofy making a joke
you get to over time decide whether i'm
gonna
gonna gonna meditate on one or i'm going
to just be run over by the other
and here's what really sucks about this
there's a part when you start to
forget there's a part when you start to
not have these things in your mind and
your brain will feel like you're losing
control of the situation
as though you had it in the first place
and you don't
and grief is that that awful
terrible beautiful process of
recognizing
there was gonna be something and it is
no more
i wanted something to look like this and
it doesn't
which ultimately means i have very very
little control
yeah and what i promise you is if you
will surround yourself by people who
care about you and
that you can be vulnerable with that you
can call on days when this is just
really heavy
if you'll continue to lean into who it
sounds like you have an awesome fiance
right who is working his butt off to
learn some skills so
to everyone who's a high functioning
autistic out there who's putting in the
work
good and those of you who know what that
what i mean when i say that
you're you're you're heroes because the
work you're putting in every day is
awesome and it sounds like you've got a
stud
of a fiance yeah and
the more you lean into him and the more
you sit down
write this young man who passed away a
letter
telling him i'm sorry you weren't that i
wasn't there i'm sorry that you died
alone
i'm sorry that nobody was there until
too late
and i want you to know that we loved you
we still think about you
every year we still remember the joy
that you brought us we still remember
the laughter you brought us
and then we're going to figure out ways
to make meaning into the future right
once you begin to let your body release
that pain that it's holding on to it
you're going to find yourself walking a
hundred pounds lighter
and you're gonna slowly start to regain
control over your physiology
and this is hard and it's not fun but i
promise
it's less hard and and not as bad as
continuing to hang on
so tight to every situation as you
mentioned every person who goes outside
every person who's by themselves where
are they who are they
hey have you seen so and so yeah it's
been like 30 seconds they just ran to
the bathroom i need to go see them
that i've got to control it all because
you
can't anna you can't
and then some people who experience this
go through
it's it's a colloquial term but it's
survivor's guilt right
it's this it's this guilt that you feel
why them two of the most damning words
you can
you can ask in the english language why
them
and not me right
what am i worth that why am i still here
why did somebody have to
pass away in that way why am i here so
here's some folks who might struggle
with survivor skill
war veterans first responders 911
survivors cancer survivors
transplant recipients natural disasters
parents who outlive their child
any number of people who experience
somebody else's trauma and they go home
in one piece they go home whole
and they just have that dark night of
the soul where they ask why me
right and it can result in flashbacks
anxiety depression obsessive thoughts
those
looping thoughts i was talking about and
anxiety
has this weird way of making its way
through the body so does depression and
it can turn into irritability it can
turn into anger it can turn into
outbursts right it can turn into
headaches
problem sleeping all of these things but
here's what survivor's guilt is
it's comparison right
it's comparison why
them and not me right in comparison
helps nothing it solves nothing
right it doesn't accomplish anything it
doesn't bring them back it just seeks to
slow you down as a way of beating
yourself
up as a way of not being able to control
tomorrow
and the reality is we don't right
you're not helping those you lost if
you're choosing to poison yourself by
hanging on to guilt
and i know that sounds harsh but the
reality is at some point we make
identity we make our identities by
hanging onto that guilt
you got to let it go and over time like
i said you'll find meaning you'll find a
way to give
right and you may need to work through
trauma with a therapist
the rule for trauma therapy was always
or for
trauma when we would show up to trauma
scenes was most people most of the time
don't need to go through a lot of
extensive counseling
they need close relationships most
people most of the time don't need to go
through
go see a psychiatrist they don't need to
go through any wild
programs that take years and years they
don't need all that
but those that do really need them i did
i was someone who needed to sit down and
process stuff with people on a regular
basis
some most people don't right so however
you wherever you find yourself anna
i want you to tell you i love you i'm
proud of you i want you to
to remind you to let this go make a
decision that this year 2021 you're
going to begin to process this trauma
you're going to find people around you
and you're going to write that guy a
letter and tell him that you miss him
and you'll love him
and you're going to let him go so thank
you so much for that call
let's go to john in toledo ohio john
what's up brother how can i help
hey dr d thanks for taking my call you
got it man what's going on
alrighty i'm just calling to talk uh i'm
just worried about my dad
um i'm worried mainly about his physical
and mental health okay
um starting with physical he's obese
probably pushing 400 pounds
we just got told he has high blood
pressure and
over over the last few years he's always
he's kept trying to go on diets and he
does well for about a month or two
and then we just can't get him to follow
along so i just want to
get your advice on how maybe to kind of
push him along and
kind of um inspire him or get him to
follow through and lose some weight
because
i'm 22 and i'm i'm kind of worrying at
this point i really want my kids to have
grandkids
to have a grand father one day so yeah
that's a beautiful why man
good for you well first i want to shout
you out dude i appreciate you loving
your old man
and to all the dads out there that are
eating or drinking or lonelying
or depressing or anxietying themselves
into tighter and tighter circles of
loneliness i want you to know
that whether they can say it or not in
the right way
your sons and daughters love you and
they miss you and they want you around
for their kids
they want you to be a granddad so john
thank you for verbalizing that in a way
that
so many people your age just don't know
how to do right
so um i've got
i've got two quick answers for you
before i just pop off and give those to
you
tell me about your dad um where did he
come from what does childhood look like
um howie explains it he had a really fun
and exciting childhood
a lot a lot of friends growing up and um
now we've kind of moved around a little
bit and we
i guess he doesn't have many friends he
has friends but he doesn't go to see him
um how's his marriage yeah is he still
married
uh oh yeah yeah him and my mom have a
great marriage
so what does your mom say about his
weight
um she tries to push him a lot and we
all talk to him about it
he says yeah i'm gonna get on it and
then he does it and he'll do great i
mean like
uh in the past two or three months he
lost probably
30 or 40 pounds and then and then it was
just like it just stalled out
and he's back to the old eating habits
and
have you ever talked privately with them
not in a group but just privately or
driving somewhere or you're having lunch
together
and you just ask them hey dad tell me
what's going on man have you ever had
that conversation i know that's awkward
for a 22 year old to have with his old
man but
have you ever had that conversation it's
hard but i've been trying a lot more and
more
i've had a lot more opportunity to kind
of sit down with them
more often like taking long drives in
the car and whatnot
so we kind of talk about that stuff a
little more but
we don't really dive super into the why
it's that way
yeah but it's just always been that way
for as long as i can remember
okay so here's the math on this
there's a million reasons why
he has allowed himself to get to be 400
pounds
it could be it could be
medical issues it could be childhood
issues it could be relational issues
that you
as his son will never ever know he'll
never divulge those
it could be trauma that he's hanging on
to it could be
that he just loves life and he loves
eating
and he doesn't care right it could be a
thousand things
you as an amateur
investigator it's gonna end up driving a
wedge in your relationship if you
try to get to the root of some of those
things and you spend your energy trying
to figure out why
okay okay so here's the hard truth
you can't do anything to
make your dad become a steward of his
body to want to be around for your
grandkids
there's nothing you can do
i do have one hail mary that i think
would be an honorable thing for you to
do
that would give you some peace and that
would give him an opportunity to hear
you
and what i would recommend doing is i'm
going to add a
a a second step to something i recommend
everybody do
right i'm always telling people to write
letters to somebody but i want you to
spend some time this holiday season
by yourself and i want you to write a
letter to your dad
and really it's going to be a love
letter i want you to talk about how much
you care about them
how much you are so thankful that he
ended up out of all the people in the
world he ended up your old man
that he's the kind of guy that you can't
wait
for your kids that you don't even have
yet to meet him
i want it to be a love letter to your
old man one that is respectful
and kind and then here's the next step
and this is gonna be hard okay are you
still with me
yes sir i want you to read it to him out
loud
okay i want you to do that in a private
setting i don't want you to embarrass
him
don't do it at dinner don't do it at a
public restaurant don't do it in front
of his
wife your mom or the other brothers and
sisters i want you to tell him that
you want to have a private conversation
with him
and that you love him and you'll never
fully know his full story
but you wrote him something that you
want him to hear
and then when it's over i want you to
hug him as tightly as you can
and then i want you to give him that
letter and tell him i love him
i love you and i'm glad you're my dad
and i'm always here for you and
i hope you'll always be here for us
and then this is heartbreaking john but
that's the best you can do then you can
love him
nobody's ever changed a behavior in a
long-term positive direction by being
nagged
or complained into
change right somebody has to look in the
mirror and say
i'm worth it and sometimes it's a it's a
different why sometimes it's a y for
grandkid sometimes it's a y
for the people around me usually though
that sort of lifestyle change especially
and i'm going to frame this as an
addiction
um man addicts don't
don't make good long-term long-term
changes
for other people they have to decide
they are worth that change
they have to other people can help
kick-start it man but they've got to
decide that john
and so do something magic and i'll any
any
son listening to this podcast to this
show
watching this on youtube
any of you you want to change your old
man's life you want you want to
fill his heart up write a letter and
then read it to him
write a letter and read it to him it'll
be the hardest thing you've ever done
it will be awkward and it will be magic
i still remember several years ago
i met my dad in a starbucks and
i just had to look him in the eye i
didn't write him a letter but i told him
hey i just need you to know you did a
good job
with me my brother my sister my family
you did a good job
and i watched a guy visibly lose a
couple of hundred pounds right in front
of me
his shoulders dropped and he just said
man thank you it means the world that
you told me that
and i wouldn't trade that conversation
for anything the only thing i wish i had
done it way earlier
and my dad and i have had my dis our
disagreements over the years as every
father and son
do but man there was something special
being able to look him in the eye
and tell him i'm grateful for you did a
good job
so john write that letter had that
conversation with him
and if you will honor all the listeners
of this podcast
uh call call me back shoot me an email
back let me know how that conversation
goes
your dad's response i'd love to keep in
touch with you and see how he's doing
and i'd love to see more importantly how
you're doing and how you're going to
continue to live your life
moving forward in the future too thank
you so much all right let's go to laura
in
austin texas laura good afternoon how
are we doing
hey thank you so much for taking my call
you bet thanks for calling how can i
help
sure so um my dad
is an alcoholic and a very skilled
liar he's stolen money from my family
i mean too many times to count including
my little sisters
um yeah in my eyes at least
i always feel like he's the victim right
i always feel sorry for him
um and another thing i think is
important for you to know just for this
call
um is that my stepdad who helped raise
me
sadly took his life when i was 18. oh
man
yeah so i'm 29 now
and my question is how do i avoid the
hurt
that follows every new lie and betrayal
from my dad
um but i'm still hoping for some kind of
normal father-daughter relationship in
my life or should i just
stop hoping and pursuing this
relationship with him altogether
yeah laura you've got to let the fantasy
go
okay and there's a nagging
question that lives deep inside your
heart way
there deep in there past where the mris
can see
that just asks almost on a daily basis
what was so wrong with laura that her
dad wouldn't love her
what was so wrong with laura that even
her stepdad wouldn't stay around
yeah and what i need you to hear me say
is
that wasn't your fault
your biological dad was sick
he's hurting in a way that he couldn't
manage and so he had to come up with
other alternative behaviors to
to manage that hurt and
it's natural and normal for you to ask
why not me
what was what was it about me that
wasn't good enough to love and i need
you to not ever ask that question again
because it wasn't about you
okay okay and when you think why did my
stepdad reach out to me
if he would just have called what could
i have done i need you to never ask
yourself that question
because he wasn't well okay
yeah you're so bright and
he didn't reach out he didn't call no
and um he was just gone
didn't leave anything right no letter no
nothing
so and so laura since you were about
five
or six or seven you've had a little girl
who has been working overtime to get men
to love her
to try to figure out a new strategy a
new way to get her dad to love
and care about her
and it's built up a universe very
similar to
whatever the arendelle whatever the
frozen
you know the frozen movies right it's
just become its own planet
right and every time there's a holiday
rolling up or every time he just shows
up unexpectedly and says hey i'm coming
by
man that castle door is fling open you
put on your dress and your makeup and
this is going to be the time and then he
leaves a mess and he leaves you with the
check or
you find out from your little brother
that he borrowed something and didn't
give it back which is another word for
stealing and fill in the blank fill in
the blank and you get hurt over and over
again
so here's what you have to do for your
soul for
any relationship you're going to have
moving forward you have to let that
fantasy go
you have to grieve the loss you should
have had a dad who loved you more than
life itself
and i hate to be the guy but you didn't
you don't and that doesn't mean you're
not worthy of being loved
okay okay so you have to
let that go and then you've got to do
the hard hard work
of and this is this is the demon of
growing up in an alcoholic home
the only way you get whole laura the
only way you get whole
is through relationships and the thing
that has hurt you over and over and over
in your life
is relationships and so you have to
lean in to other people and risk getting
hurt
again because that's the only path
towards
healing and that sucks doesn't it
it's hard yeah yeah i mean
you're so um you're so insightful you
know we've just been talking for like
60 seconds and you've you've really just
narrowed everything down
um i'm fortunate to be
in a wonderful marriage my husband is
amazing
uh awesome and a god-loving man and so
you know we
um i'm just so grateful and appreciative
for that
um but the other side of it is i have
two little sisters you know 25 year old
and a 16 year old
and so much of you know what i had to
find out about my dad i found out as i
was growing up and part of me
just fears for the 16 year old and
you know i i know i didn't verbalize
that question but i guess it's just
a kind of a continuation like how do i
protect her from
him stealing more money from her and uh
you know but without ruining her you
know the idea of her dad that she's got
in her head
as a 16 year old and so what i would
tell you laura is you're not ruining
that idea
you're protecting her he's ruining that
idea because he sucks as a dad
right and any dad who steals money from
his daughter for
alcohol any father who steals from his
children any
father who does not spend every moment
they have
making sure those his daughters know how
beautiful they are how lovely they are
how strong
and smart and ninja like they are any
dad who doesn't put that investment in
isn't worth that title of dad and so
you're not
poisoning the image what you're doing is
you're putting words to the pain that
your sister feels
knows that her dad isn't whole right she
knows that
you know what she's doing she definitely
knows she's doing what you did
which is blame herself for it and try to
solve that
right right yeah because he has just
this ability to seem like
you know poor me of course it's like
poor me why is all this happening to me
you know
yes i'm still this hot shot dad that's
right
and here's what the daughter and son
of an addict does they spend their whole
life trying to make sure dad's okay
and it's exhausting because
true addicts prey on that because it
keeps them from
ever having to face the world on their
own because somebody's always there
trying to make it okay
and the earlier you can turn that light
switch on for your sister
not that she's not gonna not love that
guy that's her dad that's your dad
right right you love him but i'm not
gonna give him my heart anymore
i'm not gonna give him my a fantasy
anymore
i'm gonna draw my boundaries to protect
me and my family
if he shows up for thanksgiving it's
going to be on my terms
and he will not be drinking we will not
give him money he will not stay at the
house and when he says
don't have a place well that stinks dad
we love you man
we'll see you soon because these are the
boundaries that are going to keep our
families safe
and that's not a dishonorable way of
interacting with your father it's a way
of protecting yourself against an
abusive person
right and absolutely you have a
husband that loves you you have won the
lottery you've put the work in
relationally
and i want you to do the deep work
potentially with your husband maybe make
it 20 21 this is the
this is the year y'all gonna go on a
marriage retreat maybe the first time
ever
and i want you to really mind your soul
and find out how much of your
relationship with your incredible
awesome husband
is built on not not a co-created
relationship together
not a co-creative future together but
you making sure he's okay too
if you've managed to avoid that you're
better than most my guess is
that you are living a life of full
support and honor and love
but sometimes that comes at the expense
of your soul and what i don't want you
to do is wake up when you're 40 and go
whoa what happened
wow right right and so
this is a beautiful moment for you to
say husband
let's just call him tom hey tom
i won the lottery with you and you're a
great good man
and i'm gonna start letting the fantasy
of my dad go
and it may mean that my little sister is
gonna spend some time with us
right i'm going to teach her how to
budget i'm going to teach her
um how to take care of her money i'm
going to teach her how to apply at
college
because dad's not going to do those
things and what i want to do over the
next few years i want to begin to dream
together and that may
mean you're going to take some college
classes that may mean you're going to
have
a child that may mean a whole host of
things that you've never even allowed
yourself to imagine because your world
has been making sure everyone around you
is okay all the time
and eventually that implodes on children
of addicts
and you are worth being loved and your
husband's worth being loved and you all
have something magical and beautiful
right now and so if you're intentional
about it way way way up front
and you're open and you communicate
honestly with one another
you may need a marriage counselor to
walk not because you're broken but
because
right because your things are so good
and you want them to be better and so
having a coach that's going to walk
alongside you will be awesome
but now this is about rebuilding a new
thing
not constantly picking up somebody
else's lego pieces and trying to stick
them back together
does that make sense absolutely and um
this call was really hard for me to make
but i am i am so grateful
that i did and thank you so much no
thank you for calling and i wanna
you just said something important and
before i let you go i wanna i wanna
honor this
it is hard to have to look in the mirror
and say i've got to let my mom go i've
got to let my dad go
i can't continue in good faith and in
good conscience to do this to myself to
my marriage to my children to whoever to
my brother and sister
because i've got a parent who sucks i
got a parent who continues to hurt i got
a parent who's dealing with their own
demons
and they're expecting their children to
make them okay
and that's not a child's job so laura
that was
i i can't imagine how hard that call was
you're brave
and you're strong you're in the ninja
club way to go dude
and more importantly you just set an
example for millions of people whose
dads
didn't measure up from whose moms had
their own demons and their own fights
and are finally going to be children who
say i'm not fighting my parents fights
anymore
i'm not i'm going to take care of my
heart my home
my spiritual walk my family
i'm going to love and honor them but i'm
not going to let them have access to my
heart anymore
because they hurt me every single time
laura you're a rock star good for you
next time um you're out on the town in
austin have some queso for me i miss the
good mexican food here in nashville and
it's killing me
so have some good queso i would say on
me but
i don't even have vinmos i don't know
how i'd pay you but you pay for it and
you eat it and say this is for delony so
i appreciate that all right so as we
wrap up today's show
man one of the greatest songs ever
written by the master
i would say he invented the blues but he
didn't but it feels good to say that but
it's not true
so you people with your cards and
letters chill out
but it's from the 1969 album completely
well
it's a cover of a 1951 song by roy
hawkins
the man with lucille bb king
singing the thrill is gone and it goes
like this
the thrill has gone away the thrill is
gone baby
the thrill has gone away you know you've
done me wrong baby and you'll be sorry
someday the thrill is gone
it's gone away from me the thrill is
gone baby you get getting the theme here
good folks he's just saying it over and
over
the thrill has gone away for me although
i'll still live on
but so lonely i'll be the thrill is gone
i'm free from your spell oh i'm free
free free now
i'm free from your spell and now that
it's all over
i love bb king all i can do is wish you
well
and good folks all i'll do is wish you
well this is the dr john daloni show
you